abundant numbers are also called  excessive numbers a number is called  abundant when the sum of its proper  divisors is greater than itself for  example the number 12 its proper  divisors are 1 2 3 4 and 6 and their sum  is 16 as 16 is greater than 12 we can  say that 12 is an abundant number and  the difference 16 minus 12 which is 4 is  called the abundance we can say that the  amount by which the sum exceeds the  number is called the abundance 18 is  also an abundant number and the  abundance here is 3. 21 is not an  abundant number because the sum of its  proper divisors is 11 which is less than  21. can you tell me the smallest odd  abundant number check the first comment  below  [Music]